Hello!
Do you know what Ms. Coffee Bean does outside
of YouTube?
She teaches machine learning at her university,
aaahm, I mean to fellow coffee beans in the
coffee machine.
Since ChatGPT came out, she cannot help but
wonder: this project proposal that a student
just submitted, was it written by the student
themself, or could it be that…
ChatGPT was behind it?
Wait, was this video script written by ChatGPT?
We think it is safe to assume that you sometimes
wonder whether an AI generated a piece of
text or not.
So, we would all like to know that there is
a way to take any text and find out whether
it, or parts of it, were written by humans
or by language models.
In this video, we will explain two ways of
detecting AI generated text.
One is a tool called GPTZero and
the other one is the idea of watermarking,
a method that seems very promising to help
at detecting text generated by language models
such as ChatGPT.
We will explain both methods and
it’s up to you to decide which method you
like best.
But before we dive into today’s topic, let’s
thank Cohere that they are sponsoring this
video.
Given that you are watching this video about
ways to detect AI-generated text, we assume
you already heard about
the incredible advancements
of natural language processing.
Maybe you thought of including the latest
and greatest large language models in your
applications?
Well, then Cohere is the right thing for you!
It lets you use extremely capable language
models to let them classify text for you or
let them generate documents.
Does this sound complicated?
Fear not!
Because it is not at all: Cohere’s specialty
is to take the finest transformer-based models
like GPT and BERT and let them do the heavy
work for you under the hood.
All you need is to write these few lines of
code to start generating text; you don’t
even need machine learning skills to use Cohere.
Just install with `pip install cohere` and
you are ready to go in Python.
So, what are you waiting for, sign up to Cohere
and start exploring it!
They just launched a
multilingual text understanding
model that works with over 100 languages.
It has state-of-the-art
results and is a top-performing
embedding model compared to others out there.
You can try out Cohere with their generous
free premium developer tier, so no credits
are needed.
Users bear no costs until they go to production.
You can sign up with this link, also posted
in the video description below.
Before explaining watermarking, we want to
see how existing systems for detecting AI
generated content, work so far.
As an example, we will take GPTZero, since
it is a very popular tool, made specifically
for teachers.
If I take the last part of the text that ChatGPT
generated for that project proposal, then
I see that GPTZero will tell us that the text
is generated by AI.
The idea behind GPTZero is to measure perplexity
and burstiness, because these two properties
of the text
vary between machine written content and human
text.
The first measure is the perplexity, of which
you have maybe heard already in the context
of language modelling.
It measures how unfamiliar a produced text
is for a model.
In other words, it is the opposite of the
probability that a sentence was generated
by a language model.
A high probability means a low perplexity.
To compute the perplexity, we go word by word
and we compute how probable it is for a language
model to have generated it, given the previous
words.
But how to get to these probabilities?
The best part is, that to build a model that
measures the perplexity or probabilities of
another language model such as ChatGPT, one
does not need direct access to ChatGPT’s
weights – access which only OpenAI has.
All one needs is a lot of ChatGPT outputs
(the more the better).
This is something that an API can deliver.
Then, one needs to train a small language
model (such as GPT-2) to reproduce these ChatGPT
outputs.
And a language model is by definition a model
capable of computing probabilities for next
words given previous words.
So, after training, when applied to text produced
by ChatGPT, the surrogate model will predict
high probabilities for text produced by ChatPGT
and low ones for other kinds of text.
And with it, we end up computing probabilities
for the whole sentence.
By multiplying all these probabilities, we
get the probability of the whole sentence
to be generated by a language model.
The perplexity is defined such, that a low
probability means a high perplexity for the
model, in other words, the language model
is surprised by the text we have given it,
since there are a lot of improbable words
in it,
and it would not have generated them, but
rather humans could have written it – or
other language models.
So, GPTZero assumes that human written text
has a high perplexity for the language model.
In turn, language model generated text would
have low perplexity,
because the high probability says that it
is exactly the kind of text the model would
have generated.
The second property that GPTZero looks at
is the so-called “burstiness” which measures
the sentence complexity.
Humans vary their sentences a lot when judging
by length and the amount of rare words they
use, so the ones on the long tail of the Zipfian
distribution that describes how frequently
we use words.
Burstiness has something to do with the fact
that for example, rare words usually do not
occur very often in our writing, but when
they do, they start to happen a lot for a
sentence or two, then not anymore.
Language models are more constant in the way
they write out their sentences.
So going on sentence by sentence, one can
plot the complexity of each sentence.
For humans, these values will vary a lot,
while for models, the value will be quite
similar for all sentences.
Then a bumpy burstiness graph will likely
belong to a human essay, while a more constant
graph will belong to an AI generated essay.
A problem with GPTZero is that it does not
always work and there are ways to fool it
into saying that AI-generated text is human
written, by introducing spelling mistakes
or tiny grammar errors.
Also, what if your writing has such a low
burstiness (thus complexity), that GPTZero
says it is AI written?
Nobody wants to be accused of that!
Then how to detect AI generated text with
way more confidence?
With watermarking, where the maker of the
model decides to deliver its models’ text
output with a unique
fingerprint that is unnoticeable for humans,
but easily detectable with statistics, as
presented in this paper.
But as it usually happens, good ideas come
from multiple places:
As highlighted in a tweet
by one of the watermarking
paper authors, OpenAI speaks about a similar
idea already, so we will not be surprised
to see watermarking coming to ChatGPT in the
future.
So, how does watermarking work?
It relies very much on what happens in a language
model when it chooses which word to predict
next, so on the so-called decoding mechanism.
A language model (be it transformer-based
like GPT or on LSTMs like older language models
were) is just this thing that having a sequence,
possibly empty, of words, can predict the
probability for the next word.
But we want text with actual words, not a
bunch of probabilities for each word in the
English vocabulary!
This is where the decoding scheme comes in:
one way to come up with a word from a probability
distribution over the words, is to take the
most next probable word – this is called
greedy decoding.
But this is not a strategy modern languages
models use for decoding,
because ok, let’s suppose we have taken
the next most probable word.
Then at the next generation step with the
language model, we would take the input text,
the last prediction and based on this and
we compute again probability distributions
for the next word.
With greedy decoding, we would again take
the next most probable word, and so on, but
this has been shown to produce very repetitive
and unsurprising text.
We humans do not like that.
So there exist more interesting
decoding mechanisms,
where one also chooses less probable words
from time to time at some of the steps, but
ensures a good overall probability.
It is here, at the decoding
step where watermarking
comes in, so where we are sampling the next
word from the predicted probability distribution
from the model.
We have.
let’s say, 50 thousand English words the
language model knows about and predicts the
probability for, given the previous words.
But before choosing the next word, watermarking
randomly sets let’s say, 20% of all these
words to a blacklist.
So the language model in decoding, can choose
only from the rest 80% of the words.
The seed for the random number generator that
chooses which words are blacklisted, is the
last word of the input.
In this way, the blacklist can be reconstructed
at any time.
This procedure is applied at each generation
of the next token, where for each next word,
the last word is used as a seed for randomly
blacklisting 20% of the words in
the vocabulary.
To detect generated text by this language
model, one needs to detect the watermark and
this is fairly easy: one goes through the
generated text and counts the blacklisted
words.
One gets the blacklist by knowing the random
number generator used to choose the blacklist
words and the seed.
The watermarked language model would not use
blacklisted words because it can’t,
but a human would definitely use blacklisted
terms.
So a text using only whitelist words is highly
likely to be AI generated and even a short
text can be classified with relatively high
certainty.
But you will think that this watermarking
procedure will produce text that looks wrong
to humans, because some words just must be
used after others.
When one says “The quick brown fox jumps”,
then of course THE plausible word there is
“over”, since this sentence is often used,
for example to show how fonts look like.
And if “over” gets blacklisted by random
sampling, then the language model will produce
garbage!
Well, the authors take care of this by choosing
when not to blacklist important stuff: If
the only high possibility to complete the
sentence is the word “over”, then the
probabilities computed by the language model
would look like this, with a high probability
for “over” and very low for others.
This distribution has low entropy, since all
of the probability mass peaks on this word.
If there were many possibilities to complete
this phrase, then the language model’s output
will have high entropy, with the probabilities
being distributed fairly equally among many
other words So, the authors make sure to never
blacklist low entropy words, but rather high
entropy cases where the model can choose other
words that are just as good as the blacklisted
words.
And, this was watermarking in a nutshell.
The authors conduct experiments with an openly
accessible model, so OPT-1.3B, but there is
no reason to believe that this method would
not apply to ChatGPT too.
They see that the watermark does not hurt
model perplexity and that the model still
generates high quality text.
We are curious to see how if implemented in
language models, watermarking will be a reliable
algorithm with no way to fool…
Ms. Coffee Bean, of course there are ways
to fool the watermarking algorithm.
If the watermarking algorithm uses the last
token as a random seed,
then anyone can reconstruct
the blacklist by using the seed and the same
random number generator.
Even if the seed is kept secret, attackers
can still brute-force their way to reconstruct
the blacklist.
If one has the blacklist, all one needs to
do, is introduce enough blacklist tokens,
which are words that humans would use, but
the language model is not allowed to.
But brute-forcing their way to the blacklist,
means that the attacker queries the API a
lot of times with the same input, in which
case, the API provider can monitor and detect
this malicious activity.
But now, let’s talk about cases of attacks,
where watermarking cannot discern whether
text was human or AI written.
One way to attack is by doing word substitutions.
If humans rewrite content by ChatGPT, then
the sentences rewritten by humans will not
be detected by watermarking.
But arguably, the text is not written by AI
anymore, it was just inspired by it.
Of course, the attacker could
also use a non-watermarked
model to paraphrase the outputs of a watermarked
model.
Changing small things, like adding spaces,
emojis or misspellings could also affect the
watermark detection, but
this could be circumvented
by careful application of text normalization,
where things like additional whitespaces are
removed.
But nobody wants to submit an essay full of
misspellings and emojis, right?
But a powerful attack is the “emoji attack”
[Goodside 2023].
It instructs the language model explicitly
to add emojis or exchange letters in its output.
If the language model is powerful enough (and
ChatGPT is), it will do so.
Even though the text quality looks bad at
first, the attacker can automatically remove
the garbage.
This would randomize the blacklist of words
following the emojis and would fool watermarking.
The authors do not have a solution against
this attack, except of training the language
model to refuse to follow such instructions
in the first place.
So we see, there are some ways to fool even
watermarking, but one could still argue that
a watermark is better than no protection.
But the clear minus of watermarking is that
it only applies when people and companies
are willing to watermark their language models
they produce.
Tools like GPTZero might be less reliable
at detection, but they apply to language models
that are not willing to do watermarking.
Since training language models becomes more
accessible, it is clear that not every language
model out there will be watermarked in the
future, unless there will
be some strict regulation
about it.
What do you think?
Would you feel better if ChatGPT were to become
watermarked?
Or you think that is just unnecessary work
that the world doesn’t need?
Let us know in the comments!
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Okay, bye!